yeah the worst obviously is uh you know
when your friend doesn't make it home
and you go to those funerals and you
pound your trident into the coffin and
you see that widow or the kids um and so
that's obviously the worst part of it um
but uh the best part of it gosh you know
i never really thought of the best part
of it
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
navy seal sniper a number one new york
times best-selling author and now author
of the brand new book in the blood
jack carr finally welcome to the reuben
report oh thank you so much for having
me on great uh great to see you i have
wanted to have you on for quite some
time first off i got to say i had to say
number one
new york times best-selling author even
though the new york times left me off
their best seller list just weeks ago
but you got the number one spot it's
still credit to you so it sort of
stabbed me a little bit i'm kind of in
the blood right now but you deserve the
credit and i went ahead and did it
anyway well i sincerely appreciate that
and as we know you know it's hard the
number one and number two maybe number
three slots on that list like it's hard
for them to ignore but they have some
flexibility down there with the with
those other ones as a uh as an editorial
uh i think it was found i don't know 30
40 50 years ago whenever that was uh
brought up to the court so uh so they
have a little flexibility there but uh
that's why the goal has to always be
number one so they can't ignore you
exactly exactly well you did get number
one it says it right here the i just
said to you before we started the cover
this book is just awesome the colors
they just it just freaking hits you got
a couple of them behind you so first off
i just got to start with i mean your
whole operation there i'm feeling very
stuffy right now you are obviously this
is you are in your your bunker somewhere
safe what's going on over there this is
true undisclosed location but i like to
be surrounded by things that that mean a
lot to me the uh the cross winkler
tomahawks that are used in the book and
that amazon actually allowed us to use
in the series and feature prominently
with chris pratt that's coming out this
summer but probably like this one this
is uh hemingway's typewriter right here
a movable feast on this it went up for
auction with a bunch of other uh
hemingway stuff in uh january early
february of 2020 so right before the
cove would panic really hit and uh and a
fan got it for me and didn't want to be
recognized but uh knew i had this uh
just a fan of hemingway and thought that
i would enjoy this and uh that i would
appreciate it and so they sent it to me
with all the documentation and the whole
thing and yeah it's crazy so uh that
inspires me as i as i write man you know
you've done something right in life when
someone you don't know buys you ernest
hemingway's typewriter that's crazy
crazy solid pretty solid so so for my
audience that that does not know you or
or only knows about you from your
writing et cetera et cetera give me a
little bit of the the history the the
navy seal all that stuff because you you
have pretty extraordinary history
yourself
well i appreciate that and uh yeah i
feel very fortunate in that i always
knew i wanted to serve my country in
uniform very early age my grandfather
served in world war ii and uh didn't
make it home he was killed in the
pacific uh in may of 1945 but i grew up
with uh the maps that used to give
aviators back then which were silk so
that if they got wet you could still use
them and they didn't disintegrate like
paper pictures of him in his squadron
his medals his wings he was a marine
aviator um so i was just drawn to the
military from a very early age and then
uh at the ripe old age of seven i found
out about seals and uh my mom was a
librarian so we went down to the local
library to do some research and uh there
wasn't very much written about seals or
special operations back then there were
a few articles here and there a couple
chapters in a in a book or two uh but my
takeaway that hey these guys are some of
the most elite special operators in the
world and the training is some of the
toughest ever devised by modern military
uh so whether that was true or not uh
seven-year-old jack was all
and the recruiter had to do nothing uh
essentially i made their job very easy
so i kept my my eyes on that for really
my entire life but i also started
reading the books that my parents were
reading in about fifth grade so that's
when tom clancy's hunt for red october
comes out and i'm reading david morrell
and nelson demille and aj quinnell and
jc pollock and mark olden and all these
guys whose protagonists whose main
characters had backgrounds in vietnam
either as like marine snipers back then
or it was navy seals or army special
forces or cia paramilitary that was a
typical background of your
action hero in the thriller genre and
then on screen as well so it was so
magical for me to read these books and i
those guys were really my my professors
in the art of storytelling although i
didn't look at it like that at the time
they were i was just a fan and i knew
that after my time in the military i
would write books like this the books
that i was enjoying as a kid growing up
so i never stopped that reading never
stopped that studying of warfare whether
terrorism insurgencies
counterinsurgencies special operations
uh that was all just a part of my
upbringing and it was part of the
foundation that allowed me to to be the
operator that i was the leader that i
was in the seal teams and then all that
comes together as i'm getting out to
write these thrillers so i did 20 years
in the steel team started out enlisted
was a sniper then became an officer
finished up as a troop commander and uh
interestingly enough that's where the
reader meets my protagonist in my first
novel he's a troop commander on his way
out and then disaster and conspiracy
strikes and off we go to the races
crazy how those things connect huh
it is and it wasn't the intent i thought
there were gonna be two separate
chapters in life but when i sat down to
write that first one it became readily
apparent that it was going to be more
than just the technical details of a
sniper weapon system or something like
that it was really the emotions and the
feelings behind certain events that i
was involved in that i could bring to a
completely fictional narrative so if my
main character james reese is getting
ambushed in los angeles i can go back
and remember what it was like to be
ambushed in baghdad in 2006 at the
height of the war and i can take those
feelings and emotions and apply them to
this completely fictional narrative
which is why i think it stood out to
simon schuster who sees thousands of
books like these cross their desks every
year yeah give me give me like the best
and worst
moment of of being a seal i i suspect i
can guess the worst but maybe maybe the
best
yeah the worst obviously is you know
when your friend doesn't make it home
and you go to those funerals and you
pound your trident into the coffin and
you see that widow or the kids um and so
that's obviously the worst part of it um
but uh the best part of it gosh you know
i never really thought of the best part
of it but i think it's the entire
experience in that you are you have a
purpose you have a mission uh your
passion is being the best operator that
you can possibly be uh you owe that to
the guys to your right and left to their
families uh to the team to the country
as a whole to that entire entire mission
so i think it's that i guess it would be
the uh having that purpose that is so
clearly defined and when you're
downrange being solely focused on that
task in hand and not having to worry
about anything else not worrying about
the leaky faucet or the gutters or the
baby that's crying or whatever it is you
are solely focused on that task at hand
building patterns of life on your
targeted individuals and then going out
and grabbing them in the middle of the
night to bring them back ask them a
couple questions and then uh go go take
out the rest of that network so um
having that that purpose that is so
clear i think is is probably one of the
best parts so one of the things that i'm
always amazed by is that those those of
you guys that have been in the military
been sealed been in the navy whatever it
is or people that have been in the cia
the fbi just a couple weeks ago i had
brian dean wright on the show i don't
know if you know who he is but he's a
former former cia guy um people that get
out and then do things that are
ancillarily related to this whether it's
talking on youtube for a living whether
it's writing books that are either
fiction or non-fiction everything else
how do you blend
you know some stuff that they probably
don't want you to talk about there's a
way that you have to fictionize some of
these things
you don't want to get in trouble you
don't want to become a character in one
of your books how do you take all of
those things and make it honest and
sensible and also you know not so you're
going to get yourself killed literally
right so a lot of people think on the
outside looking in that navy seals know
all sorts of secret stuff and uh you
know maybe there's a couple things here
and there but really what we're doing is
what every major city swat team is going
to do tonight they're going to go serve
a warrant they're going to go do a do
either a no knock or a knock warrant
somewhere they're going to bust in and
they're going to grab a fugitive
so we're doing that same thing except
ours happen to be in in baghdad or kabul
or somewhere somewhere like that and we
have a few more maybe assets at our
disposal to build these these targets
build these target packages and then go
prosecute these targets but there's not
much secret about it i mean you're just
you're going up and kicking a door in
the middle of the night and grabbing
somebody out of their bed essentially
and uh but but you know i still wanted
to make sure that i was uh complying
with all the everything that i'd signed
in the military and i didn't want to
give anything anything away and at the i
was still closely related it's closely
connected to my military time for that
first novel so i submitted it to the uh
like i had got some lawyers and they
said yeah we recommend you submit this
so i did and they took out i think like
nine sentences so not not much was
pretty good and they back to me with uh
with 45 days they advertise uh 30 and
what you sign says they will get back to
you in 30. they got back to me in 45 i
thought that was pretty good for uh for
the government so i did the second one
as well that one month went by then two
then three then four then seven and we
had to push the publication date uh and
they got back and they took out 54
sentences passages words um so at this
point i can afford a little bit
afford some more attorney fees so we go
and we appeal and we tie each and every
one of those redactions to a publicly
available government document so not to
someone's book or to wikipedia but
something anyone in the world can
download from our very own government uh
they let me win on 37. so now you can go
to the paperback and you can look in
there and you compare it to the
hardcover and you can see what they were
concerned about but that i won on appeal
one of those things i made up a
completely fictitious cia black site in
morocco they took out morocco they took
out moorish architecture they took out
the atlas mountains they took out
everything that uh could pinpoint where
it what country this can i had no in my
military experience no touch points with
uh moroccan intelligence services or
military anything like that i just made
it up but by doing that appeal what are
they telling us well now they're telling
us that there's probably a cia
so if they've done nothing it would be
would have been more beneficial to them
than had they gone through this process
so i did that for the first three novels
the the third one they when we appealed
they got back and said hey uh we're not
gonna let you appeal and i took that as
uh you know quit bothering us kid with
these fictions we're not gonna let you
appeal that's probably the best thing
you can hear from the government in your
stream
i'll take it if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about lifestyles instead of non-stop
yelling check out our lifestyle playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're both right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell